- Rumble Boxing is the group fitness class
that combines boxing
with strength training.
Its popularity in the group fitness scene
has grown since it first
opened its doors in 2017,
and celebrities are taking notice.
Walk into a Rumble class on any given day,
and you just might be
throwing a few punches
alongside Justin Bieber,
his wife, Hailey Bieber,
maybe even David Beckham.
Celebrities aren't just working out there.
They're investing. Justin
Bieber and Rocky himself,
Sylvester Stallone,
have invested in Rumble.
The New York-based workout
is growing rapidly,
with studio locations popping up all over,
from Philly to DC to LA to San Francisco.
Noah: You know you're gonna get
half the class on the bags,
working traditional combinations,
getting your conditioning,
getting your cardio in,
and getting that all-empowering,
just, aggression out.
And you know over here on these benches,
you're gonna get a strong weight workout.
So you're gonna do your
squats, your lunges,
your curls, your shoulder presses,
sprinkle in a little
burpees, all with, you know,
under the red lights,
under the black lights,
surrounded by a group
of just great, like-minded people
having fun and working hard.
- The price of a Rumble
class is comparable
to other New York
boutique fitness studios,
at $36 per class.
But it could vary slightly
depending on which city you're in.
And if a big class
isn't really your thing,
you can also choose to work
one-on-one with a Rumble trainer
to get more personalized attention.
The individualized training of course
includes perfecting your boxing technique
plus working with weights.
The private training sessions
in Manhattan start at $175,
a little higher than other boxing studios,
such as Overthrow or Shadowbox,
which start at around $120 per session.
Regardless of price, people
clearly can't get enough
of Rumble, so my colleague
Kevin and I are going
to Rumble's Upper East Side
location here in New York City
to check out what the hype is all about.
The class is 45 minutes and
is made up of 10 rounds,
switching from the bag side to
the weight side continuously.
It was nonstop movement!
If we weren't punching the
bag during the boxing rounds,
we were on the floor doing sit-ups.
When we were watching the instructor
demonstrate the strength-training moves,
we were bouncing around to
keep our heart rates up.
We started on the bags,
and by the time we got
to the weight section,
my muscles were on fire.
But the lights, the music,
and the hyped-up instructor
definitely helped me push through.
From there, we moved on
to the private training session with Noah.
This private training option is one
that celebs will often take.
Noah went over the boxer stance
and the six boxing punches
for us, so we can perfect our form.
We then did rounds of squats,
shoulder presses, and push-ups.
As if our muscles weren't already tired,
we then threw punches on the bag.
To say we were reaching
fatigue at this point
was an understatement.
Kevin: I loved the class.
It was a lot of fun.
It was big, high energy.
It was fun to go in there
and hit the bags on one side
and then switch over to
the weights on the other.
It was not like any other
class that I've been to,
where most of the
classes are just directed
at one type of thing that you're gonna do
for the entire time.
And it was fun to have the options of
going back and forth on this.
Fabiana: I loved the high energy
from the trainers, the
energy all around the room.
The music was great.
It was just, like, super motivating.
Kevin: Even though it was really dark,
and it kind of closed you
off, I did find a lot of times
that I wasn't sure
exactly what I was doing
because of the lighting,
so I felt a little lost.
But also that was a thing that allowed me
to not worry about what
was going on around me.
I don't think it's
overpriced for that at all.
Fabiana: Right, I totally agree.
I think it's a fair price.
It's not astronomically higher
than other places, and you're
like, what am I getting
for that money?
Kevin: And you're gonna
spend the same kind of money
if you're going out for a few drinks
in Manhattan, so.
Fabiana: There's something to say
about the energy of a class
and just having all
those people around you,
and just the whole
experience of a Rumble class.